and while driving and recording videos
never the safest thing to do this was
taken near desert inn and jones just
before two o'clock this afternoon in the
thick of it it didn't take long for the
rain to build up on the roads and start
to pond ted has been tracking the storms
throughout the afternoon but first arco
mana joins us now live from the east
valley where there was a swift water
rescue earlier
well denise that swift water rescue
wrapped up about an hour and a half ago
and everyone is safe it happened here at
the flamingo wash where earlier was
filled from downpours from the rain and
the rushing water can get dangerous
crews were seen near the wash when we
first got here just after three this
afternoon we saw large objects floating
in the water including a mattress clark
county fire tells us three people were
stranded in about a foot of water they
were rescued safely and there were no
injuries now these are viewer videos of
the rainfall from across the valley
today cars were drenched near the i-15
in jones and people from neighborhoods
in north las vegas to henderson saw the
heavy rains most of the activity cleared
up pretty quickly
las vegas fire and rescue reports three
construction workers were injured near
lindelof and charleston after lightning
hit the ground five feet away from them
so a reminder if you hear thunder be
sure to seek shelter either inside a
building or a vehicle and for a closer
look at the weather let's send it to
chief meteorologist ted florendo in the
studio our